good evening I'm Elizabeth mcclain and
I'm very pleased to welcome you to the
annual dinner on the 270 ahthe
anniversary of the library company's
first meeting we're delighted that so
many of our members and friends have
turned out for this occasion and I'm
particularly pleased to acknowledge Meg
Morton from the fidelity announce
foundation several members of the Drexel
family Victor Drexel people like this
kind of wave Ed Biddle Toni Biddle's
Francis Gowen and Frances trained two
administrators from Drexel University
Carol Montgomery and mark Greenberg
who are representing the university
president Constantine Papadakis who
unfortunately can't be with us tonight
we welcome all of you who are not yet
part of a library company family and we
cordially invite you to consider joining
the ranks of our members let me draw
your attention to the booklet you found
on your seat an update on our capital
and endowment campaign the cover
indicates that we're approaching the 8
million mark of our 10 million dollar
campaign but in fact I can now happily
report to you that we've crossed the 8
million threshold thanks to the generous
support of so many of you
in the booklet you'll read more details
about our spectacular acquisition of the
Michael Zinman collection of early
American imprints and about the progress
we're making renovating the Cassatt
house and transforming it into a
residential research center and here
thanks to our member of Etsy Scott who
is here this evening for giving us a
handsome start to the furnishing thereof
we could use others when these are
exciting times for the library company
and we are grateful that you are all
sharing and this excitement with us
unless you think we deal only in
esoterica because our core collection is
literally invaluable in early American
imprints I also call your attention to
the op-ed in today's Enquirer its sites
Sally Griffin's account of the yellow
fever epidemic of nine 1793
using two contemporary accounts in our
collection and drawing comparisons but
with our present anthrax crisis it ends
advising us to take the best of the past
and not repeat its mistakes and we're
better to learn this lesson than at the
library company so well now without
further ado let me turn the podium over
to our librarian John Van Horne who will
introduce this evening speaker
Thank You Elizabeth
it's a great pleasure to introduce dan
Rotenberg to you he's an accomplished
journalist and business writer with
eight books and hundreds of articles to
his credit over a career that now
approaches 40 years for about half that
time he has been pursuing an elusive
subject the most influential financier
of the 19th century who paradoxically
tried to avoid the limelight Anthony J
Drexel gave no interviews destroyed most
of his personal papers and held no
public offices he seemed to prefer that
others particularly his protege and
partner J Pierpont Morgan received the
credit for his innovations
drexels immense contribution to the
nation has gone largely unrecognized
until Dan Rotten Berg's persistent
efforts have documented the extent of
that service and then will shortly be
describing to you just what those
contributions were the library company
has a great interest in the financial
history of our nation most of you here
tonight know that just over two years
ago we initiated a new program devoted
to the study of early American economic
history with the help of the fidelity
foundation of Boston we decided to
stretch our definition of early a bit
beyond its usual end around the mid 19th
century in order to bring you a talk
this evening on one of the seminal
figures of later 19th century American
financial history and we have another
reason to take an interest in Anthony J
Drexel because we have an important
connection with the Drexel firm the
library company's first building which
was constructed in the 1790s was down at
just on Fifth Street just south of
chestnut and we vacated that building in
1880 in order to move to our new
building which had just been constructed
on South Broad Street the well-known
Ridgeway library building this is now
the building that houses the
Philadelphia high school for the
Creative and Performing Arts when we put
the fifth Street building on the market
in 1880 the board directed that a
respectable real estate broker offer it
for sale at a price not less than
$60,000 just a month later they
authorized the agent to sell it for
$50,000
but finding no buyer we ended up leasing
the building to the American news
company for four thousand dollars a year
for ten years then in 1884 a special
meeting of the directors was called to
consider an offer which came seemingly
out of the blue from Anthony J Drexel of
one hundred and five thousand dollars in
cash for the library building and an
adjacent property that we own needless
to say this offer was readily accepted
so Drexel was putting together a group
of parcels into a large lot on which he
was planning to erect a new Drexel
building so our building came down to
make way for the new Drexel Company
building Anthony J Drexel may not have
been ostentatious in his person but he
was certainly extravagant in his
buildings in New York he chose Wall
Street as the site of that city's branch
and he commissioned an opulent building
the likes of which the financial
district had never seen likewise in
Philadelphia the Drexel building was a
magnificent marble structure considered
by many to be the handsomest private
banking building in the world
it had 398 rooms a great many of the
newfangled inventions called elevators
and at 11 stories it was the tallest
building in the city affording visitors
to the rooftop travillian panoramic
views of Independence Square and the
rest of the city within two years of its
opening the Philadelphia Stock Exchange
took up quarters in the Drexel building
making fifth and chestnut the financial
capital of Philadelphia alas the Drexel
building came down in the middle of the
nineteenth century
when so much land around the Statehouse
was being cleared to make way for the
new independence National Historical
Park and now occupying the site that
once provided a home both to the library
company and to the Drexel company is the
library of the American Philosophical
Society
ApS alerted society founded like the
library company by Benjamin Franklin had
elected Anthony J Drexel to membership
in 1892 and when they were designing
their new library building in the 1950s
the Society replicated the facade of the
library company's building that used to
occupy that same
from 1790 to 1880 so we come full circle
and now it is my privilege to introduce
to you dan Rotenberg
thank you John actually John mentioned
that the the drexel building at fifth
and chestnut came down he meant he meant
the twentieth century not the nineteenth
century some of you probably remembered
it came down in 1956 I think when
independence
Independence Mall was was first opened I
was preparing my remarks for tonight and
John van Horn assured me that the annual
dinner of the Library Company of
Philadelphia is the leading scholarly
gathering on the East Coast I just
wanted to make sure my audience here is
there anybody here tonight who can tell
me the name of the founder of the first
great American department store John
Wanamaker and company anybody
can anybody tell me the name of the
founder the great the first great auto
maker in America the Ford Motor Company
nobody how about the great American Bank
of the 19th and 20th centuries JP Morgan
& Company any ok this is obviously a
very illustrious group it is not JP
Morgan the founder of JP Morgan &
Company was Anthony J Drexel who also
founded many other things that don't
have his name on it on them either it's
a great honor for me to be here with
such an illustrious group who obviously
know something that most other people
don't know a few years ago I asked
they found the chairman of Drexel
University who was himself an investment
banker if he knew who founded JP Morgan
& Company and he didn't so you're you're
a relatively rare company here I want to
return the compliment of bringing me
here by taking you away from here let's
all go back in time to a Wednesday
afternoon in March of 1871 March 8th to
be exact and let's remove ourselves 90
miles to the north to New York City but
this is not the world beating New York
City that you and I have grown up to
know this is very much the little old
New York of Edith Wharton's novels in
fact this is before Edith Wharton's
novels Edith Wharton was only nine years
old on this particular day
this is a very provincial town confined
to the limits of Manhattan Island
there's certainly no World Trade Center
but also there's no Empire State
Building there's no Rockefeller Center
there's no Grand Central Station
Pennsylvania Station there isn't even a
Woolworth Building there isn't a
Flatiron Building there isn't even the
Brooklyn Bridge I mean there's nothing
we're talking a very sleepy town on the
surface nothing seems to be going on on
this particular Wednesday March 8th of
1871 but beneath the surface there's
something very important happening in
this town there is a financial community
on Wall Street but again it's nothing
like the Wall Street we know today
mostly it consists of a lot of very
petty grasping traders and speculators
and they're operating in these little
ramshackle three-and four-and five-story
walk-ups which I can only describe to
you as Dickensian and in fact some of
them date back from before Charles
Dickens was born so here we are in New
York it's 1871 we're on Wall Street
let's take a peek inside one of these
little buildings and there's a cramp
Tulum office at 53 Exchange Place and we
look in the window and here we see a
confused and depressed young banker who
is going through the motions of
conducting business his name is John
Pierpont Morgan he's 33 years old but
this he's nothing at all like the great
JP Morgan that you and I have read about
in books he's in fact a profoundly
unhappy and unfulfilled young man from
his perspective his whole life seems to
be in shambles his banking partnership
is about to expire he's obviously a
bright and well-connected young man but
he's already been tarred on Wall Street
with a reputation as someone who's very
difficult very brusque very tough to
work with not popular at all on top of
that he has all kinds of health problems
he's plagued by severe headaches
constant fatigue insomnia fainting
spells he's suffering from
rare skin condition that causes
eruptions in his skin and that makes his
nose burst out and big red blotches
meanwhile he's receiving letters
regularly by mail from London from his
father who is constantly lecturing him
about his lapses in character he really
has no further use for money he's making
about $50,000 a year at a time when vast
majority of Americans are making less
than $500 a year and he has no real
desire to continue in business and he's
already written his father that he plans
to leave Wall Street and he's going to
settle down and he's sort of going to
live like an English squire maybe he'll
raise some prized dogs or heard of
pedigreed cattle or something like that
well around 4:30 on this particular
afternoon
JP Morgan emerges from his building with
a suitcase in hand he hails a
horse-drawn carriage which takes him
about four or five blocks to the steam
ferry at the foot of Liberty Street here
he climbs aboard the five o'clock ferry
which takes him across the Hudson River
to the Pennsylvania railroads immense
Depot in Jersey City there was no
railroad tunnel to New York at that time
and this is a huge Depot it's the wonder
of its age full of ticket offices and
waiting rooms and restaurants and then
there are 12 tracks with trains headed
north south east everywhere but West
here he boards a train that will deposit
him that night at 8:45 p.m. at the
Pennsylvania railroads new depot at 32nd
and Market Street in Philadelphia so
that's a total trip of 3 hours and 45
minutes which seems very long to you in
those days everybody was very excited
about this connection only before the
Civil War it took twice as long and
within the memory of a lot of people it
had once in the 1820s taken 20
two hours to get from Philadelphia to
New York or back and you had to train
change ferries and take a couple of
trains
why is JPMorgan making this trip to
Philadelphia he really doesn't know all
he knows is that two months earlier he
got a letter from his father telling him
that Anthony Jay Drexel may want to see
him about a certain matter and six days
ago Morgan received a letter from
Anthony Drexel himself inviting him to
come down for dinner at his mansion in
West Philadelphia one of Morgan's
characteristics throughout his life is
his unquestioning devotion to his father
so his father tells him to go see
Anthony Drexel he's going here he is on
the train to Philadelphia very unhappy
man but he's going to have dinner with
this stranger he's never met before and
to stay overnight at Anthony drexels
home okay let's shift now the same day
let's shift down to Philadelphia let's
look at JP Morgan's mysterious host this
is Anthony Drexel he's 44 years old 11
years older than Morgan he's a bald
stout man he's got medium height ruddy
skin heavy Brown mustache which is his
principal characteristic he's the
driving force among three brothers who
built a small family currency exchange
into a influential private bank of
tremendous reputed wealth right now it
has branches in New York and Paris it's
got an operation in Germany it had
branches at one time in Chicago and
during the gold rush in San Francisco
the father of the three Drexel brothers
Francis Martin Drexel was an Austrian
artist who had fled Europe during the
Napoleonic Wars when he was a teenager
somehow he wound up in Philadelphia
painting portraits he never quite made
as a portrait painter he was competing
don't forget with some of the great
painters of the day ultimately he gave
up painting and he opened his currency
brokerage on Third Street which was then
financed Philadelphia's financial
district that stretched from Walnut
Street to Market Street and this was
1838 Anthony Drexel his middle son went
to work there a year later at the age of
13 and he's been working on Third Street
ever since Anthony Drexel is a very much
a creature of habit so it's easy for us
to imagine how he started this day in
March of 1871 in the morning he gets up
at his mansion on 39th and Walnut Street
he's one of the first people to settle
out in West Philadelphia he gets up it's
nice day comes out of his mansion and
walks three miles into town to his
office at third and chestnut along the
way he stops at 22nd and Walnut Street
to pick up his best friend George W
child's who's the publisher of
Philadelphia's leading newspaper the
public ledger at a child's mansion and
together these two old friends and their
also business partners
proceed down Chestnut Street with such
punctuality that shopkeepers are said to
set their watches by the moment that
these two men pass and as he passes he
nods waves to everybody very politely in
one sense everybody in Philadelphia
knows Anthony trixl in another sense
nobody knows him other than his best
friend child's as John Van Horne already
mentioned
Anthony Drexel is a very private
self-effacing man he goes out of his way
to avoid the limelight
now for all of his apparent influence
and power and wealth
Anthony Drexel has a problem and the
problem is that he is a banker and
bankers have to be where the money is
the money in the United States in those
days was primarily concentrated in
wealthy individuals in three cities
Boston Philadelphia and New York but of
those three New York is far greater for
its concentration of wealth than either
Boston or Philadelphia and the real
money in the world is in London and
Paris Drexel has opened an office in
Paris about four years before this but
he needs very much he has this office in
New York he needs very much a really
aggressive driving dynamic person to run
his New York office he also needs to
establish some kind of banking
connection in London so he's got a plan
here he's going to put this young JP
Morgan in charge of his New York office
and in the process this is going to
create an alliance for him with Morgan's
father Junius in London Junius Morgan is
very interested to see this happen
because he wants somebody to keep an eye
on his troubled son JP so here we are
it's by now it's it's 8:30 p.m. the
evening of March 8 1871
Anthony Drexel is in his carriage
waiting patiently at the West
Philadelphia depot for JP Morgan's train
to arrive what's going to happen well
remember we're back on March 8th 1871
now so we don't have the benefit of
hindsight we haven't seen the script in
advance we don't know how this story is
going to end but we do know that Anthony
Drexel is a instinctively a mentor he's
the kind of person who seems to make
good things happen to
anybody who crosses his path with the
support of Anthony Drexel an obscure
banker named Jay Cooke has become
America's financial savior during the
Civil War raising about seven hundred
million dollars for the Union cause with
drechsel's financial support his closest
friend George childs has evolved from a
penniless clerk into the celebrated
proprietor of one of America's most
respected newspapers again that's the
public ledger and of course you and I
know now today in in 2001 that Anthony
Drexel is about to engineer an even more
dramatic transformation within Pierpont
Morgan himself
Morgan is about to meet the first
businessman other than his father whom
he could really admire and respect and
Drexel didn't merely offer Morgan a job
he offered him 50% of the profits of the
New York office he offered him
tremendous capital support and then as
John mentioned in 1873 he erected for
Morgan a huge magnificent what was then
a huge magnificent seven storey building
at the corner of Broughton wall street's
which towered over everything else in
Wall Street really was the wall it was
the World Trade Center of its day and
overnight it really redefined the
landscape of Wall Street and the
psychology the way people who worked on
Wall Street thought about themselves and
looked at each other
Anthony Drexel did all this for this
confused and really unhappy
underachieving young man JP Morgan you
could say that Anthony Drexel
demonstrated more confidence in Morgan's
future than either Morgan himself felt
or Morgan's father and thanks to the
remarkable chemistry generated by this
relationship
we now know as we're looking back from
this date and 1871 that JP Morgan is not
going to retire to a life of books and
art collecting and grand tours of Europe
as he had planned instead over the next
40 years Morgan is going to build and
expand America's great railroads he's
going to create the world's first modern
corporations US Steel International
Harvester several others and he's going
to impose some sense of order on the
destructive forces of the market for
better or worse
from this moment on Morgan's name will
become synonymous with America's
transformation from a rural agricultural
society into a modern industrial State
Anthony Drexel is about to change JP
Morgan JP Morgan is about to change the
world now in my book I tried to recreate
this day and I called it the day the
world changed and of course in the past
two months you know a lot of people are
saying well September 11th that was the
day everything in the world changed and
you know very often we look back at the
seminal events that we think are
changing the world and we always look
back and there's some disaster either
it's the attack on the World Trade
Center or it's the dropping of the first
atomic bomb or it's Pearl Harbor or it's
the great stock market crash of 1929 or
it's you tell me the fall of
Constantinople in 1453 whatever it's
always a disaster it's always something
everybody knows about but as I hope the
scene that I've just painted for you
demonstrates the world is really
changing every day in ways that we're
not quite aware of
even as we go about our daily business
there are great things happening behind
the scenes that we're not aware of and
in times like this year when everything
seems to be going wrong on the surface
that strikes me as a very reassuring
thought now I've brought copies of my
book along and I'll be happy to answer
questions and sign copies later for
anyone who wants one there's a table in
the back there but before I do I wanted
to leave you with another thought
Anthony Drechsel really exemplified the
old adage that there's no limit to what
a man can do if he doesn't mind who gets
the credit I I think you've all heard
this I tried to find out who actually
originally said this and I tried to
trace it down on all kinds of source
databases on the internet and I the best
I could find was it was attributed to
Ronald Reagan it's got to be older than
that and if it was Ronald Reagan I guess
it was one of his speech writers but
Anthony drexels success really stemmed
from his willingness and even his
eagerness to let the Morgans and and
others like George childs take credit
for whatever contributions he made he
tried to bury his own accomplishments
and so as John has told you for that
reason it took me 23 years to pieces
life together it's not just Anthony
drechsel's papers that are gone
incidentally it's that great drexel
building on Wall Street that John
described that's gone
Anthony drexels mansion at 39th and
walnut is gone the four-story bank that
the drechsel's erected in 1854 on Third
Street and what was then the financial
district that was knocked down in 1976
for a parking lot
the 11-story bank as John mentioned that
they built at fifth and chestnut in 1888
that was knocked down in 1956 or
independence Park but after 23 years of
searching for traces of Anthony Drexel I
am here to tell you that some things do
survive if you search long enough so I
want to leave you with one other time
trip I've tried to take you on a time
trip here I want to take you on one more
that you can take yourself and this is
one of the wonderful things about
Philadelphia
we don't have snow-capped mountains and
we don't have beaches and we don't have
a Sugarloaf Mountain but we do have
wonderful built environment much of
which has preserved in spite of the fact
that a lot of it has been torn down as
anybody read the novel its mark Hal
ferns novel soldier of the great war a
wonderful novel about an Italian soldier
in World War one who witnesses an
absolute atrocity to one of his loved
ones he sees it at a distance and it
just utterly devastates him and he has
to carry this memory through the whole
war and it gets at him so that he
finally starts rationalizing in his own
mind he says maybe what I saw with my
own eyes didn't really happen maybe
something else happened and he starts
constructing an alternative scenario and
sure enough it turns out that scenario
is in fact what happened wonderful book
I highly recommend it and I really
haven't given away the best part of the
plot I had a similar experience like
this when I was working on this book
early in my research in the in the 1970s
I was rounding up as many Drexel
descendants as I could find and one of
them said to me you know the original
Drexel building at the
34 South third Street is still there the
bank building and I get very excited and
I went down there and of course I found
this parking lot that I just told you
about and I like the soldier in this
novel was totally devastated I mean how
could they do this to me how could they
do this to posterity or the memory of
the drechsel's and for several years I
was beside myself and then I started to
stop and think well Francis Drexel
opened his first currency exchange of 34
South third Street in 1838 and then in
1854 the drechsel's put up a new bank
building at the same address 34 South
3rd Street and that's the building that
was knocked down in 18 and 1976 so I
said to myself well you know if they put
up a building at the same address they
must have been somewhere else for a
couple of years while that new building
was going up so I said there's got to be
some trace of the drexels left on Third
Street and I started going back to the
old city directories and sure enough you
know each year up until 1854 they would
they were listed at 34 South 3rd Street
and then all of a sudden 1854 they're
listed at 22 South 3rd Street and for
about 3 years they're listed at 22 South
3rd Street and then around 1857 they're
listed back at 34 South third Street
again so I figured ok this makes sense
they they moved to another address for
three years and then they moved back
into their new building so very excited
I got on my bicycle and went down the
3rd Street again 22 South third Street
it's an old church it sits there and
it's now a restaurant some I think it's
so what is it Wichita steaks something
like that so I this could not possibly
be the the drechsel's office and again I
was stymied and then I came across a
clipping from a Philadelphia newspaper
8th January of 1854 describing the
wonders of this new building that the
drexels have just opened and the new
building is at 22 South third Street but
it's the same building that was torn
down a 34 South third Street in 1976 so
I went over to the Historical Commission
I said what's going on here and they
said well that's very easy to explain in
1857 the street numbering system was
changed
so all the buildings changed their
numbers so the building that was 22 is
now 34 I said oh okay fine and then
suddenly I said well wait a minute if 22
became 34 and the drechsel's were
originally in a building at 34 what's
that 34 building now well they looked up
they have a they have a chart showing
what the old addresses and the new
addresses were and they said well that
building is now 48 South third Street so
I looked up in the folder at the
Historical Commission under 48 South
third Street and sure enough this is the
building where Francis Martin Drexel
opened his currency exchange in 1838 it
was just a coincidence that their first
two buildings both had the same address
34 South third so lo and behold here's
this building that historians thought
had been knocked down and it's still
there and you can walk over there today
and I urge you all to do it it's an
incredible experience it's four doors
north of Chestnut Street there is a shoe
repair shop on the bottom floor there
are two little apartments on the second
and third floor it's a three storey
house that has been it was totally
gutted and renovated in the 1870s and
then it was gutted and renovated again
in the 1970s the only remnant left from
Francis Martin drechsel's day is a
curved dormer on the top of the
but if you take my book there is a
picture in this book of 3rd Street as it
appeared in 1859 a photograph walk down
there with this book and you will see
that just about all the houses that are
in that picture in 1859 are still there
on 3rd Street right now and take a walk
into this little it's about 14 feet wide
this little shoe repair shop there is a
Korean shoemaker in there doesn't speak
a word of English I walked in there very
excited I showed him this picture I said
hey look this is your this is your story
says no no it's not me he he thought I
was from the Immigration Service I think
but what I'm trying to say is there's no
trace of the old office inside there now
it's all been renovated the the counter
where Anthony Drexel worked as a 13 year
old boy is no longer there and he used
to sleep under the counter sometimes his
father would make him stay overnight and
be the night watchman but just go in
there look around and say to yourself
this is where the drexels got started
and 35 years later they were running the
world then I want you to take a good
look at this shoemaker he's performing
these repetitive and seemingly very
trivial tasks and remember back in the
1830s the drechsel's were performing a
lot of very trivial and repetitive tasks
also and then ask yourself where will
this shoemaker and his family be in 35
years from now point I'm trying to make
is that somewhere on this planet
at this very moment there are potential
Anthony drexels potential JP morgan's
who are going to change the world for
the better and right now they're
laboring in obscurity they're waiting
for some mentor or patron to call them
to greatness
Anthony Drexel is no longer around to
perform that task so now it's up to you
and me thank you
we have time give time for some
questions and John says we have time for
some questions if I may say c-span is
you're taping the presentation this
evening and we do have time for
questions but we also have a microphone
a portable microphone so if you'd like
to ask a question please raise your hand
and don't ask it until the microphone
arrives at your seat thanks
yes the building next door is that how
what is that connection yes good
question
the Drexel building right next door at
15th and walnut that's that was put up
by Drexel and company in 1927 they were
in the the Drexel building at fifth and
chestnut from 1880 1888 actually 1885
until 1927
they put that building up it was at 15th
and walnut 1927 modeled after a
Florentine Palazzo and of course
wonderful timing two years later was the
stock market crash they didn't stay
there very long and build were they were
they still there bill booth is here bill
booth be who was with Drexel and company
from 1946 as they moved out in the early
40s and as you know what is it now it's
a it's a health club I think right
but that was of course long after an
Anthony Drexel died in 1893 so that was
long after after his day yes Val
the question was what bridges were in
existence in Philadelphia between that
between Philadelphia and Center City I
between West Philadelphians and Senator
city that that's a good question I know
that the bridge across Walnut Street was
there the main reason that West
Philadelphia started to be settled was
that the trolley lines were extended out
to to West Philadelphia sometime in the
1850s don't forget that's that's when
the consolidation of the city really
began
but Anthony Drexel was really he was the
idea in those days was you you wanted to
especially if you were a second
generation immigrant family as the
drechsel's were you wanted to
demonstrate that you were part of
society and Anthony drexels father moved
to Rittenhouse Square
Anthony Drexel lived there for a year or
two but then he decided I don't need
that and he moved out to the 39th and
walnut he bought that entire block from
38th to 39th between walnut and Locust
and subsequently built houses there for
four or five of his children two of
those houses survived there there now
fraternity houses at the University of
Pennsylvania yes this is just a footnote
to the Third Street
experience of Drexel and Co because next
door to Drexel and Co on Third Street to
the north was the office of Chauncey
bullet who was the lawyer for Anthony
Drexel in the 1850s and there
laughter and the founder of a firm today
that bears the name through several
mutations of Drinker Biddle and wreaths
and every time that Drexel moved
Drinker Biddle and wreaths logically
moved in coordination so that when
Drexel left third Street Drinker Berlin
wreaths moved to erect a new building on
4th Street just south of the drexel
building on 5th Street and when the
drechsel's moved again to Walnut Street
by Frank orbital in wreaths then known
as Dixon Butler and Micucci moved in
coordination again in the 1400 block of
Walnut Street so that that marvelous
syncopated development continued on
until the middle of what we now
reverently call the last century and
Bill bullet are built both they will
remember that that relationship which we
at the firm regarded as inevitable in
all enduring ended sometime in the late
60s or early 70s for reasons which he
and I still mourn today you're quite
right the drechsel's were at 34 South
third Street John Bullets office was at
32 South third Street right next door
you should remember in those days there
were no no telephones there there was no
telegraph even in the 1830s 1840s and of
course no fax machines and no internet
so physical proximity was really
important and the in those days the the
the great wholesaling houses were on
Market Street and all the merchants from
the Midwest from Illinois and Indiana
and Ohio about twice a year would come
in to Philadelphia to stock up on
supplies for the next season and they
would bring with them the notes of their
banks
in Indiana or Illinois which were really
it was sort of like if I were to give
you Italian money right now you probably
wouldn't want it so these guys would pay
for their merchandise with these
banknotes from from the West and then
the the wholesaler on Market Street
would go around the corner he would go
down third Street to all these little
currency exchanges and see who would buy
these banknotes from him
and who would give him the best price so
that's that's the way the world was and
that's why the financial district was so
small and and so compact in those days
and why but for the same reason you had
to have your lawyer right right next
door to you a totally different world
anyone else
ah
paid a pretty bleak picture of the young
JP Morgan why did Drexel pick him good
question why why was Anthony Drexel so
attracted to JP Morgan why did he give
him such a good deal I think the
original attraction was Drexel wanted
really wanted a partnership with Junius
Morgan in London and on one of his trips
to Europe I mean he had some kind of
relationship with with Junius Morgan
they had known each other I would say
for about 15 years and Junius Morgan
told him I've got this problem with my
son in New York Drexel was saying I've
got this problem with my bank with my
office in New York and the two of them
sort of cooked up this this arrangement
together
I think Drexel got very Excel started
with this problem with his new Europe
office then he realized hey I the New
York office is small potatoes compared
to an alliance with a banker in London
because London is where the real money
was just as now Americans are investing
let's say in China China's dependent on
on the dollars from from American
investors America at that time was
really dependent on the investments from
the Britons and to a little lesser
extent the the French and the Germans so
I think that was really the original
hook and then as Drexel got to know
Morgan in the next couple of months
while they were setting up this office
he came to realize and he became Drexel
became the greatest advocate for Morgan
in with Morgan's father so you have
Drexel writing letters to Morgan's
father's saying you know your son is
really pretty terrific guy and you
shouldn't be so hard on him he's really
he's going to be a first-rate business
man father never thought he would amount
to anything
so I think that's I think that's what
happened it wasn't really
originally that he was he cared that
much about JPMorgan but he did care a
lot about Junius Morgan in London see
someone way in the back I'm sorry the
relationship I'm Katherine Drexel good
question I'm glad you raised that the
relationship between Anthony Drexel and
mother Katherine Drexel who is now Saint
Katherine Drexel this is one more case
of a famous protege of Anthony Drexel
mother Katherine Drexel was Anthony
drechsel's niece
and she her father a died when she was
about 25 Anthony Drexel became the the
executor of her estate of her father's
estate and he became her really de-facto
guardian there was a very close
relationship between the Anthony Drexel
and Katherine Drexel and I'm sure you've
all read about mother Katherine you've
read about how pious she was you've read
about how she gave up her fortune to
live in a convent done I think 41 cents
a day you know how she set up a network
of missions to educate Blacks and
Indians which was unheard of in those
days
this is 1889 we're talking about I think
what what a lot of people don't realize
is that the thing that really made
mother Katherine Drexel such a success
was her tremendous financial acumen and
her entrepreneurial instincts she was
really the only member of that third
generation of drechsel's who had any
interest in business and Anthony Drexel
was as I said a natural mentor so he
taught her about bonds he taught her
about how to set up a business and
basically the network of missions that
she and schools that she set up was
really modeled after the network of
banks that he had set up so I'm glad you
asked that question because that's
something I didn't even get into in my
remarks but it's one more support of the
point I'm making which was that Anthony
Drexel made an awful lot of
things happen that he never got credit
for well thank you I am going to oh wait
we have another I'm sorry we have
another question
dan it's Tony Biddle hi Tony as Anthony
J Drexel Biddle I guess I'm a human
example of the incestuous nests of
Philadelphia here here and here we go
yes and not only you know the great
institutions of Drexel and Company
Drinker Biddle and Reese and so on and
so forth
I want to say thanks to you for your
long lifelong dedication to this project
thank you very much from the family and
Anthony J Drexel was my great great
great grandfather and I'm you know we
have always been very proud of the
family very proud of what they've done
and frankly very proud of their
willingness to not take credit but you
thank you sir have given us something in
writing about all that and I do
appreciate it thank you very very much
Dan well thank you
on that note I think I will adjourn to
the back table there if anybody would
like me to sign a book or to talk to me
further I'll be back there thank you
very much
and thank you all for coming the evening
is adjourned